et caught up with Dave Chappelle outside  of Muhammad Ali's funeral and Louisville  Kentucky on Friday the comedian shared a  priceless memory of the late boxing  legend forgive me the story behind this  picture you were two years old I mean I  was - I don't know what was going on I'm  I knew exactly who he was I don't know  how my mom arranged dad but that's the  first time I met my mother  and you fell in love with him right oh I  loved him before that you had a show  last night you have a show tonight you  made the time to come here today why we  miss it for the world  this is beyond royalties he's bigger  than all the kings of the earth and and  that's why we're here  you